la carcasse de l'appareil j toujours sur
l'aérodrome sur place les enquêteurs de
la gendarmerie des transports aériens
effectué des relevés
emmanuel nichols est encore sous le choc
elle est la première à être arrivés sur
les lieux
même si c'est des gens qu'on connaît pas
c'est la famille de l'air quoi et que ce
soit un ulm un avion un parachutiste
ça remue toujours oui ça c'est sûr au
lendemain de l'accident les membres du
club du lm cherche encore à comprendre
ce qu'il s'est passé car des conditions
de vol étaient bonnes et les pilotes
expérimentés et surtout du pilote bien
c'est un gars qui pilotent pas très bien
la veille
claude ben ali ni lui aussi pilotes
avaient volé avec le septuagénaire
disparu
impossible pour lui de croire à une
erreur humaine c'était un très bon
pilote
c'est un gars qui s'était vraiment
expérimenté mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé on ne sait pas est ce que c'est un
problème mécanique
est ce que c'est il a eu au dernier
moment peut-être un malaise est ce qu on
sait pas on sait pas on ne peut pas dire
se crashe vient s'ajouter à une liste
déjà trop long pour le maire de
saint-florentin
il déplore quatre accidents mortels ces
dix dernières années
séoul à la formation des pilotes qui
étaient pas suffisantes ou et
l'entretien des machines qui est pas
suffisant il ya seulement quinze jours
on est un élu ump a perdu sa roue devant
le bar
donc oui et quand même c'est pas normal
tout ça l'autre occupant de l'appareil
est toujours hospitalisé à auxerre et
son état de santé serait stable l'
enquête de gendarmerie elle se poursuit
pour déterminer les circonstances de
l'accident